foreign the woke object to these terms
of respect they want the few and the
proud to stop saying sir or ma'am out
loud a new report suggests the Marine
Corps is considering dropping gendered
language to avoid offending or
misgendering leadership
they should get punished with push-ups
for that except women suck at push-ups
would say
recruits would be banned from using
phrases like sir or ma'am when
addressing superiors in turn drill
sergeants will ask recruits their
pronouns before calling them maggots
pencil necks and sissies
[Laughter]
gender neutral identifiers like a
person's rank would become the preferred
way to address senior members the policy
recommendation comes from a two million
dollar study commissioned by the corps
which concluded that traditional ways
Marines address each other could be seen
as offensive and to think the Pentagon
could have used that two million bucks
for traditional expenses like 400
Hammers and 600 toilet seats
luckily some top brass within the branch
are pushing back refusing to Cave to the
woke pressure of course most active duty
service members and Veterans know this
is all garbage like how even Fox
employees know Greg's bodyguards are
just a tax write-off
as for whether the change actually gets
implemented remains to be seen but those
inside the core say just like DeVito's
underwear it won't be changed overnight
it's just how necessary so how does this
happen with you you're a writer on the
show how do these lines get through look
take it up with Joe Mackey
okay well Dagan uh do you think making
our military nicer in this PC way is a
good idea
I don't think this sir or ma'am
confusion is a new thing is a 21st
century woke issue and I'm speaking from
personal experience as you can probably
see I have a little too much
testosterone
I am flat chested I have this weird like
six pack neck
that um I look like I have an Adam's
apple for more than a decade I had this
really short haircut I thought I look
like Winona Ryder but I look like Vince
Vaughn
and I wasn't in the Marines obviously
but it's really awkward you know you're
standing in in a restaurant and somebody
comes up behind you and Taps you on the
shoulder and says excuse me sir you're
standing on my foot
and you turn around and it's your date
[Laughter]
so to just get rid of ma'am and sir just
alleviate a lot of pressure and hurt wow
this is amazing okay Jim you know it's
this is why we have these kind of talk
show discussions because people have all
sorts of perspectives I thought
everyone's going to attack this and it
might not be an interesting segment what
do you think are the military onto
something with this study no
first of all are Marines getting
offended by words then maybe they
shouldn't be in the front line fighting
they're worried about that I thought the
only way to offend the Marine is ask if
he's in the Navy you know
but could you imagine like an alpha male
drill sergeant screaming in a recruit's
face do you understand me he's like yes
he she they them
lbgq TV whatever the hell it is
it's so true Lydia this is I I don't
think and I I said it in the read there
that that the the rank and file or
probably most of the leadership wants
this the problem is they hire these
consulting firms none of whom are
military types and they make their
recommendations that would probably work
at their dump company right
the study is the length of Anna Karenina
so after three years two million dollars
and all that effort they had to come up
with something that was provocative and
new and interesting and they landed on
this I don't like being called ma'am but
the alternative that they suggested is
that you just use someone's last name
which sounds very chaotic because I
can't remember people's names right like
how does like yes shalu like it just
doesn't have the same ring to it yeah
and I just think it's a recipe for
conclusion confusion I also think
there's a lot of confusion as well
because I mean are we gonna have to
change all of the songs to non-gender
them like The Battle Hymn of the
Republic are we gonna have to change it
from he sounded forth the trumpet to
they've sounded forth to Trump I just I
don't know where this where this ends
are there any sort of yeah obviously it
doesn't end and uh but that's
interesting you don't like being called
ma'am is that something why is it
old-fashioned or does it sound like it
sounds so stodgy yeah but again I don't
have an alternative well southern people
are raised to say yes ma'am yes sir no
ma'am no sir yes and people don't like
it makes them feel old but it sounds
which I understand now hey you
that's true Joe a lot of these recruits
a lot of the military types like she
said these are like you know Young
Southern men they love the tradition
they want to join the corps because of
these Traditions right yeah well I think
it's so strange I mean sir and ma'am are
such terms of respect and look at the
other things Marines call each other
they call each other Grunts and jar
heads I can't imagine Marines saying you
know it really hurt me when you referred
to me as a Jarhead
and only that but the the bullets they
shoot at other people are very hurtful
too
they are yeah I think we're just getting
close can we just say well let's just
call each other comrade isn't this
what's all heading toward that we can
just call each other comrade we can get
rid of uh titles we can get rid of
pronouns we can just say great Point
comrade and then we'll say that while
we're standing on the bread lines
everyone would be much happier yes it is
true and I mean Dagen I understand that
your perspective but really these uh
troops they want to
they want to experience these Traditions
right that they they're more traditional
type of people and uh I think that the
women who go into the military they're
tough they're not the type that are
going to get offended by these things
are they and the guys as well
um if I was a General Sergeant I would
love for the grunts
to screw up as much as possible so I'd
have a reason to yell at them so
um let them misgender me so I have a
reason
exactly try complaining right uh I think
lost in all this is that the military
has long been I mean racially and in
terms of gender they were far ahead of
the rest of society and they always have
been so uh here's to you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else